[Music]
the internet is full of photos that
prove the world can change in a blink of
an eye
from once-in-a-lifetime shots of
wildlife to pictures that show
interesting perspectives
these photos are impossible to reproduce
if you are first time you are click the
red subscribe button and prepare to be
in awe of these 10 pictures taken at the
right moment flamingos inception
wildlife photographers have to deal with
unpredictable animals as their subjects
but to Bobby Haas is surprised he was
able to capture one of the best
unpredictable moments ever while he was
wrapping up a photo shoot from a
helicopter the flamingos he was
photographing suddenly changed their
formation the birds unknowingly
transformed into a large flamingo and
the picture is now considered the holy
grail of wildlife photography ice-cream
thief walking on a boardwalk surrounded
by birds comes with its risks from a
potential attack to getting bird flu on
you you are taking your chances but when
Tara Dell and Tara was snapping a photo
for her Instagram she didn't know what
she was in for Tara was taking a photo
of her ice cream with the boardwalk as
her backdrop when a seagull decided to
steal her treat Tara was able to take a
photo of the sneaky ice cream thief and
it is hilarious and a little sad at the
same time bat two-faced not only was
this picture taken at the right moment
but this dad's fast reaction may have
also saved his son's life Shawn
Cunningham was enjoying a spring
training baseball game with his son
while his son became distracted with the
photo he had just snapped a player sent
two baseball bat flying towards his face
thankfully Cunningham was paying
attention and was able to block the bat
with his forearm cunningham sustained
bruises from the blow but his son's face
was unharmed
rainbow lightening considering rainbows
don't happen too often and it's nearly
impossible to capture a photo of
lightning the fact that this picture
even exists is amazing
while Greg McKeown was busy taking
photos of a storm in Tuscon Arizona a
rainbow formed wanting to capture the
moment McCown stole a quick show and
notice the flash in the corner of his
eyes when he went to look back at what
he captured he couldn't believe his eyes
he was able to photograph a stunning
photo of a rainbow and a lightning bolt
in the same
dog bubbled there is nothing cuter than
capturing animals playing with bubbles
it's like their mind explode from the
confusion and excitement when this
person was capturing their dog's playful
moment a freeze-frame locked her beloved
pet inside a bubble but by the look of
their dog's face she's having the time
of her life in her soapy bubble prison
shark high-five they are some of the
scariest predators in the world so
surprising to find a picture of a
smiling shark but that isn't the only
thing that makes this photo impressive
not only is this the happiest shark in
the world it is also the friendliest Eli
Martinez was diving in the Caribbean
when this shark darted towards him
instead of going for his jugular the
shark quickly took a turn reached out of
spin and gave him a cheeky high-five
walking butterfly sometimes well-timed
photos become amazing works of art this
older gentleman was just going for a
stroll around the block when someone
snapped a quick photo the results are
beautiful and worthy of their own wall
mural it looks like the men who's using
crutches to walk grew a pair of wings
and is ready for takeoff even the
antennas from the butterfly painting
behind him are perfectly atop the older
man's head curious cheetah it's not
every day you have a run-in with a baby
cheetah when bobbi-jo Clow was on a
safari in Tanzania she found herself
face-to-face with a curious cheetah
the young cat jumped onto her car and
pizzas head into the sunroof Clow was
able to snap a few photos of the moment
and this one looks like the cheetah is
getting ready to jump inside thankfully
the cheetah just sniffed clouds hair
then returned to his mother after she
called it back trans-asia Airways
accident
there are many fake photos of an
airplane hitting a bridge circling the
internet but this photo of the
trans-asia Airways flight 235 captured
by a dashboard camera is very real and
very scary
the shocking photo captured the moment
the plane collided with the bridge in
Taiwan before crashing into the river
below the wing of the aircraft even
clipped in taxi and the aftermath is
captured in the photo miraculously 15 of
the 58 people on board survived feeding
frenzy sometimes it isn't just capturing
the photo at the right time it is also
being at the right place at the right
time this picture looks like it is
something out of this world
but it's actually a rare shot of several
humpback whales feeding while touring
the coast of Alaska a wildlife
photographer stumbled upon a group of
humpbacks bubble feeding the feeding
method includes several whales using
bubbles to blow fish to the top of the
water while other whales breach the
surface to swallow them the photos the
moment produces are astonishing to say
the least
which of these is your favorite picture
taken at the right moment react in the
comments section below and don't forget
to like this video and subscribe to the
things
[Music]
you
[Music]